issei sagawa surnommé le japonais
cannibale cet homme est un anthropophage
il s'appelle issei sagawa japonais né à
kobe il ya 32 ans
c'était le 11 juin 1981 il ya tout juste
40 ans à paris issei sagawa un étudiant
tu violes et mangeant partie renert welt
une jeune néerlandaise sagawa avait
connu rené à revel au centre de censier
où il étudiait la littérature comparée
elle le considérait comme un bon
camarade mais lui était amoureux et la
poursuivait de ses avances après le
meurtre l'étudiant la découpe puis la
cage dans deux valises le 13 juin
il prend un taxi et seront en bois de
boulogne pour se débarrasser du corps là
en face du chalet des îles
il avait tenté de jeter ses deux valises
dans le grand lac samedi vers 20h30
mais il a été vu et les valises
sanglantes sont restée sur la berge
la police a été aussitôt averti lé
enquête a donc été courte très vite il
sait que sa gas oil est arrêté il est
d'abord interné dans un hôpital
psychiatrique à villejuif avant d'être
déclaré irresponsable de ses actes
l'homme bénéficie d'un non-lieu
puis est transféré au japon en août 1984
tout d'abord il était anormal qu'ils
soient à la charge des contribuables
français il y à une décision définitive
de non lieu parce que il est infirme
mental et dans ces conditions il n'y
avait aucune raison de le conserver au
japon sagawa est placée dans un hôpital
psychiatrique mais ne peut être jugé à
cause du non lieu définitif prononcé en
france résultat il est libéré le 13 août
là bas les médias français s'intéresse
toujours à lui
il est même interviewé par une équipe de
télévision pour le journal de 20h de tf1
cannibalisme ci n'est pas moi ce n'est
pas les choses horribles
ce n'est pas des choses 500 chose ce
n'est pas à d'autres
c'est une sorte l'expression d'un an les
années suivantes le japonais cannibale
deviennent célébrités au pays du soleil
levant il écrit plusieurs livres reçoit
un prix littéraire participe à des
émissions de télévision et se lance
aussi dans la pornographie
je n'ai jamais essayé d'être vais l'être
jusqu'à maintenant qui ne possède
aujourd'hui
issei sagawa est toujours vivant âgé de
72 ans il vit dans la banlieue de tokyo
dans un relatif anonymat
[Musique]